[Musique]
à willencourt on se bat depuis un centre
d'année pour la pédagogie mixtes
c'est-à-dire une partie en présence et à
l'école et une partie à domicile on
appelle les jeudis essentielle la
pédologie présentiel il faut quatre
conditions
la première c'est d'abord d'avoir un
réseau de qualité il faut être fibrés
c'est le cas donc ça c'est les
institutions mairie qui a poussé à cela
ensuite il ya le rôle des profs
l'épreuve font une sur formation et de
façon complémentaire en 10 arrivent
elles encourent à saint-quentin
troisièmement il faut que l'enfant soit
très forme très bien formé aussi onu au
numérique et qu'il est il souhaiterait
aller relais avec une tablette on a
rajouté un quatrième élément qui a joué
un rôle pour obtenir ce premier prix
national c'est les parents on a formé
aussi les parents pour qu' il soit un
environnement ils fassent du
renforcement positif
il ya une bonne cohérence conseil
régional un conseil départemental mairie
agglo et puis en même temps paris saclay
oui l'ensemble fait qu on est plutôt
performant sur la formation et on
accélère et c'est vrai que cette crise a
augmenté la culture numérique a augmenté
l'appétence ceci numérique aussi bien
des adultes que que des enfants